[Musik]
rechtsanspruch auf home office
mindestens 24 tage im jahr will
arbeitsminister heil garantieren immer
höhere infektionszahlen frankreich
bekommt die korona pandemie nicht unter
kontrolle
und wieder macht probe in minsk
zehntausende bürger trotzen dem regime
von alexander lukaschenko
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg der nachrichtenüberblick
am sonntag guten abend und willkommen wo
die tanne ist auch dabei für den sport
hallo und guten abend
es wäre ein novum in deutschland das
recht mindestens 24 tage im jahr von zu
hause zu arbeiten
arbeitsminister heil hat ein gesetz dazu
entworfen schließlich habe die korona
krise gezeigt dass sehr viel mehr
heimarbeit möglich ist als gedacht
seit der pandemie arbeiten viel mehr
menschen von zu hause aus im juli und
august waren es 14 6 millionen nach
einer studie des arbeitsministeriums
sind das 36 prozent der beschäftigten
vor einem jahr waren es 24 prozent
daniel pontzen berichtet für viele wurde
es dieses jahr von heute auf morgen
lebenswirklichkeit home office mit all
seinen vor und nachteilen
doch auch in nicht pandemie zeiten soll
das recht auf arbeiten von zu hause
bleiben zwei tage pro monat so lange
keine betrieblichen gründe dagegen
sprechen es geht darum dass wir die
rechtliche situation der beschäftigten
stärken damit sie flexibler arbeiten
können es geht nicht darum irgend jemand
ins home office zu zwingen sondern die
möglichkeit zu schaffen da wo das
betrieblich möglich ist ablehnung vom
koalitionspartner die arbeitnehmerschaft
werde so in zwei teile gespalten
zulasten derer die nicht zu hause
arbeiten können auch für sie müsse man
maßnahmen finden um familie und beruf
künftig besser zu vereinbaren fordern
gewerkschafter home office möglich ist
dürfte es indes ruhig ein bisschen mehr
sein
wenn wir ernsthaft eine bessere
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
erreichen wollen wenn menschen mehr
zeitsouveränität erhalten sollen dann
sind ein tag alle 14 tage anspruch auf
home office ein bisschen spärlich laut
gesetzentwurf sollen sich arbeitnehmer
und arbeitgeber zusätzlich auf mehr tage
home office einigen können ein neues
arbeitszeit recht fordert ergänzen die
fdp 11 stunden ruhezeit wie bisher gehe
im home-office oft an der realität
vorbei niemand soll mehr arbeiten und
weniger pausen machen aber die
einteilung muss freier sein ohne dass
die menschen wie heute faktisch illegal
agieren arbeitsminister heil will seinen
gesetzentwurf nun ihre so abstimmung
geben
rede und antwort steht arbeitsminister
heil in ein paar minuten in berlin
direkt gleich nach uns
gesundheitsminister sparen will
pflegebedürftige und ihre angehörigen
finanziell entlasten
so sollen heimbewohner für die
stationäre pflege maximal 700 euro pro
monat zahlen und das höchstens drei
jahre lang finanzieren will sparen das
nicht über höhere beiträge sondern über
steuermittel
das robert koch institut meldet in
deutschland 2279 neue corona infektionen
seit gestern so viele wie noch nie an
einem sonntag
am wochenende sind die zahlen in der
regel niedriger weil nicht alle
gesundheitsämter berichte abgeben
im sieben tagesdurchschnitt haben sich
täglich 2140 menschen neu mit dem corona
virus infiziert gestern lag der wert
noch bei 2090 einen neuen corona
höchststand gibt es in frankreich mit
gestern fast 17.000 neuinfektionen
das auswärtige amt waren schon länger
vor reisen in fast alle regionen des
landes
auch im freien gilt dort in vielen
städten eine masken pflicht in marseille
mussten sämtliche restaurants und cafés
schließen
und heute thomas walther in paris waren
eigentlich weitere verschärfungen
erwartet worden
ja der gesundheitsminister droht den
großen städten seit tagen eine
verschärfung der maßnahmen an wenn sich
die lage der nicht bessere
die lage bessert sich nicht aber die
angekündigte verschärfung ist bislang
zumindest ausgeblieben
die stadt paris beispielsweise wehrt
sich mit händen und füßen dagegen dass
hier auch alle bars und restaurants wie
in marseille geschlossen werden da soll
morgen zu hören wir weiter verhandelt
werden
dabei ist die lage hier mindestens so
kritisch wie in marseille mehr als 260
von 100.000 einwohnern sind mit dem
virus infiziert das zeigt aber wie
schwer sich die regierung damit tut
landesweit einheitlich maßstäbe nicht
nur aufzustellen sondern sie auch
durchzusetzen und das erhöht nicht
unbedingt ihre glaubwürdigkeit man
wartet hier mitunter sehr lange auf
testergebnisse
es gibt keine vernünftige ausreichende
kontakt verfolgung das virus offenbar
grundlegende grundsätzliche schwächen im
gesundheitswesen frankreichs und im
politischen entscheidungsprozess die
einschätzung von unserem frankreich
korrespondent urs verhalte dankeschön
uhr ins präsident tom geht es besser
auch er hatte sich mit corona infiziert
nach auskunft seiner ärzte ist er jetzt
fieberfrei kann möglicherweise schon
morgen das militär krankenhaus verlassen
und ins weiße haus zurückkehren
zuvor hatte sich jump in einer
videobotschaft gemeldet er sagte bei
seiner einweisung in die klinik habe er
sich nicht so gut gefühlt nun sei aber
auf dem weg der besserung
vor fünf jahren hatte der papst seine
letzte enzyklika veröffentlicht jetzt
kommt wieder ein rundschreiben vom
oberhaupt der katholischen kirche
darin fordert franziskus die korona
krise müsse zum wendepunkt für mehr
mitmenschlichkeit werden die pandemie
sei ein neuer beweis dass der markt die
wahren probleme nicht lösen könne
und auch die migrationspolitik müsse von
mähren nächstenliebe geprägt werden nach
belarus als reaktion auf die sanktionen
der eu hat machthaber lukaschenko allen
auslandskorrespondenten die
arbeitserlaubnis entzogen
trotzdem arbeiten kameraleute weiter um
diese bilder
zu verbreiten denn auch heute ließen
sich zehntausende demonstranten nicht
einschüchtern
für begann berichtet unversöhnlich
stehen sie sich gegenüber
diejenigen die das regime lukaschenko
verteidigen sollen und die belarussen
die seit acht wochen für freiheit und
demokratie auf die straße gehen
ihr müsst euch wohl verstecken dieser
protest sonntag ist den politischen
gefangenen gewidmet trotz straßensperren
und wasserwerfern schaffen es einige
demonstranten vor die berüchtigte
münster haftanstalt christine hunderte
fälle von folter in billa russischen
gefängnissen sind in den letzten wochen
bekannt geworden erst gestern steinmann
der während einer friedlichen
demonstration festgenommen worden war
todesursache sturz aus einem stockbett
diese offizielle version glaubt hier
kaum jemand
wir haben keine gesetze wovor sollen wir
also angst haben sie haben uns mit
granaten beworfen mit wasserwerfern
beschossen
wir hatten keine angst jetzt schicken
sie uns sms mit drohungen und wollen uns
so einschüchtern
aber alles umsonst wir sind hier dass
die europäische union sanktionen
beschlossen hat gegen 40 funktionäre des
lukaschenko apparats mark für brüssel
ein durchbruch gewesen sein
für die demonstrierenden ist das zu
wenig das ist in haft man bräuchte
strengere sanktionen
unser wunsch wäre dass die sanktionen
noch effektiver werden noch härter in
erster linie gerichtet gegen die
geschäfte und geldbörsen von lukaschenko
zehn vielleicht 100.000 haben heute
allein in minsk protestiert sie wollen
weiter machen bis sie ihr ziel erreicht
haben und das heißt demokratie für
belarus
nach dem schweren unwetter in
südfrankreich und norditalien suchen
rettungskräfte weiter nach opfern und
vermissten
die starken regenfälle haben am
südlichen alpenrand schwere schäden
angerichtet
in italien starben mindestens fünf
menschen einige orte sind von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten
eine gruppe deutscher wanderer wurde auf
einer hütte entdeckt und in sicherheit
gebracht
das zdf trauert um einen langjährigen
kollegen michael jungblut bekannt
geworden ist er als moderator des
magazins wiso dort war er bis 2002 zu
sehen 1986 sendete er die erste west
sendung aus der damaligen ddr jungbluth
schrieb lange für die zeit und
veröffentlichte zahlreiche bücher
er starb am donnerstag mit 82 jahren
zunächst mit tennis schluss im
achtelfinale bei den french open in
paris für den durch eine erkältung
geschwächten alexander zverev gegen
yannick sinn das erst 19 jahre alte
große talent aus südtirol verliert die
deutsche nummer eins in vier sätzen
schon im ersten satz fliegt der schläger
bei der deutschen nummer eins zu viele
probleme häufen sich auf er ist
gesundheitlich angeschlagen seit ein
paar tagen der starke wind macht ihm zu
schaffen
und natürlich auch sein junger gegner
denn der spielt mutig und ohne respekt
dominiert die partie
zverev kämpft er stemmt sich gegen die
drohende niederlage variiert sein spiel
und kann zumindest den dritten satz für
sich entscheiden aber die kräfte beim
deutschen schwinden mehr und mehr mit
einer krachenden vorhand beendet jannik
sympathie 6 2 3 6 3 4 6 und 6 3 der
junge mann aus südtirol trifft jetzt im
viertelfinale auf rafa
im ersten der beiden heutigen bundesliga
spiele gab es keine tore wolfsburg und
augsburg trennten sich 0 zu 0 beim
london marathon ohne zuschauer und
hobbyläufer hat sich bei den frauen
vorjahressiegerin und weltrekordlerin
brigit kosgei aus kenia durchgesetzt bei
den männern gewann nicht der große
favorit eliud kipchoge sondern theater
aus äthiopien
vier kilometer vor dem ziel musste der
kenianer eine spitzengruppe ziehen
lassen gibt google landete schließlich
auf platz acht den sieg in dem rennen
ohne zuschauer und hobbyläufer in st
james's park sicherte sich in einem
zielsprint der äthiopier schura kita
seine zeit 2 stunden 5 minuten und 45
sekunden
der deutsche rekordhalter arne gabius
verpasste als 22
die olympia norm um fast 3 minuten ja
das war der sport am sonntag mit grauem
himmel und das wetter gewährt auch
weiterhin keine großen lichtblicke
morgen regnet es entlang des rheins im
osten gibt es schauer an der ostsee sind
gewitter möglich
die sonne zeigt sich nur selten
zeitweise weht ein lebhafter wind die
temperatur erreicht 10 bis 17 grad
und so wechselhaft bleibt auch erst mal
machen sie sich noch einen schönen
sonntagabend marietta slomka begrüßt sie
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn